on the hill tonight for the Giants will
be Dominic Leone this will be the third
time that he has been an opener in those
previous two starts he's had three clean
Innings and uh the average fastball in
the high 90s that's what you're going to
face when you see him everything's a
hard release so here's Trent Grisham
up the middle
on the backhand La Stella to Belk and
that's how this game gets started nice
play with La Stella going to his right
this easy for a second baseman to open
it up going to your right having to come
across I mean it's not a great play Mike
but if you're a second baseman in the
big leagues this is a play that you got
to be able to make
and the Stella does a good job well he
sends speed back to the Padres Dugout
with this effort
but he got that ball right at the shoe
tops here's tatis who swings and Pops
this one up for belt
belt doing the pop-up dance
shades of the baby giraffe in Milwaukee
about 10-15 years ago a bit awkward but
beautiful here's the former pirate Adam
Frazier an All-Star this year with the
Pirates
more work for La Stella
and that'll do it two ground balls and a
pop-up and now the Giants are coming up
the garbage fresh off a good outing
against the Angels well you Darvish
making his 27th star we talked about him
throwing against the Giants at Oracle
Park nice era under three so here's the
lastella he's got four home runs and
he's got 20 runs batted in
Centerfield hit well grips him back at
the wall out of here a lead-off home run
for Tommy Las Stella to put the Giants
ahead one to nothing right now here's
Levant way Jr one ball and one strike
get out into triple Valley can Grisham
get there he Dives it's off
the wall
Here Comes Ruff he's going to score wade
into third with a triple
Grisham almost had it tell you what if
he makes his play it's one of the best
plays we've ever seen in the gap
and he really came close to pulling it
off
another little cutter trying to wrap
around the outside corner and Wade takes
it through the power Gap right center
and watch Gresham as to how close he
comes to this and I think he overshot
the runway he did I think
he overdose
not by much and he went a long way to
get get close to that he might like to
have a shot at that one again I'm sure
he's mad about it here's Longoria 11
home runs 40 driven in Wade the runner
at third Crawford at first 1-0 pitch
driven to left hit well it is out of
here
Longoria with home run number 12 and
he's back folks and is it great to have
him back and now it's a five run first
inning for the Giants down here in the
third inning and Grisham at second base
here is Fernando tatis Jr as a Padres
trying to get on the board here and chip
away at what is a five-run deficit
there you go to right and that is going
to be off the wall from second base
comes Grisham he will score Fernando to
second base with an RBI double Padres
are on the board it's 5-1 San Francisco
here's your shrimsky who popped out in
the first inning Giants with a 5-1 lead
they scored all of their runs in the
first inning
hit well into center field on its way
it is a head Mike yes dremski takes
Darvish deep six to one Giants his 23rd
home run of the year and the third
Giants home run of the night eight pitch
at bat and it ends up with a long ball
Mike yastremski
very impressive there that was no cheap
home run either
unloads number 23. Brandon Belt against
Darvish blasted the Deep right field
this one is way gone up over the arcade
Brandon Bell the booming home run is
24th of the year
eight to one Giants just teeing off on
you Darvish tonight the fourth Giants
home run in the first four Innings wow
what a good bat that was
stremsky had just tied belt for the team
lead and belt surges right past him
again with number 24.
crew big fly
423 feet
that Home Run Tracker is gonna go on the
fridge here it's 8-1 Giants a new
pitcher now Jose Alvarez on for his 56th
appearance
got him tied him up with a fastball at
92 miles an hour one away now Adam
Frazier
on the ground to Second for La Stella
you see Brandon Bell the O2 pitch
plasma Strikes Out Swinging to end the
inning Alvarez with two strikeouts
Fernando tantese Jr
this is very high and maybe out of play
no it's coming back and could Sally puts
it away so you can get a lot of push in
this ballpark from the stands back to
the field behind home plate down the
right field line and watch casali's path
plants now here it starts to drift not a
problem no puts it right in the sweet
spot if I go down I go down if you
enjoyed that play
second and third nobody out and here is
Evan Longoria
swinging there's a bloop into Shadow
center field and that is falling and in
there base hit Frazier was racing out
from second he couldn't catch up to it
Grisham coming in from Center it was
well in front of him
and Evan Longoria gets his fourth RBI of
the game nine to one Giants Crawford
moved over to third two seem fastball
that ran way in in the hands of
Longoria he did not hit it hard at all
but he really muscled it over the
infield it was amazing how far 21 078.
watching the Giants trying to clinch a
playoff spot
got him and that's the ball game and for
the Giants they are headed to postseason
for the first time since 2016 and a big
hearty congratulations it's the earliest
time that they have ever clinched a
postseason birth in franchise history